hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei easyjet heute aus
ägypten hier sind tatsächlich in ägypten
und wir machen gerade zum ersten macht
zuerst mal in meinem leben einen
pauschalurlaub matthias dazu schon ein
pauschalurlaub gemacht hier benutzt oder
pauschalurlaub typ aber einmal vor
bis 16 vor 17 jahren war ich auf meinem
team sind also ein pauschalurlaub ist
etwas typisch deutsches um das heißt man
fährt irgendwohin man kauft ein paket
flug hotel essen alles drin all
inclusive zu sagen und das haben wir ja
hier matthias hat ein grünes bändchen
das heißt er kann rund um die uhr essen
essen essen und das witzige ist hier in
diesem ressort wir sind hier in einem
ressort gibt es nur deutscher touristen
fast nur deutsche touristen und wir
wollen euch deswegen heute mal zeigen
wie sich der typische deutsche im urlaub
nimmt
[Musik]
ja unser erstes thema heute ist deutsche
beschweren sich immer die ganze zeit im
meer leiten erkenne ich hab hunger zwei
minuten wird sicher schon das nennt sich
fünf sterne hotel
also mein physiotherapeut in dortmund
ist viel besser jetzt auch schon
abgefallen ja gleich am ersten tag ich
angekommen bin
doch das größte reichen oft nicht zu
gast wir sind eher sehr bedacht ganz
ganz höflich zu sagen ja und ärgern uns
aber ganz lang bevor wir sagen das ist
mir auch schon aufgefallen
du hast auf zu manchmal hast du die
gleichen gedanken wie ich aber du mir
sagst es erst nach drei tagen genau und
ich sag direkt wenn ich hier ankomme und
ich sehe irgendwie es jetzt das internet
zu dicht dann wird direkt sich beschwert
ja das geht ziemlich einwohner tokios
supervisor aber nicht nur deutschland
meckern ja nicht nur zu den leuten hier
sondern die meckern auch untereinander
so leute so ich habe schon öfter so
katar hier beobachtet die gehen dann so
gemeinsam hier rum und meckern sich
gegenseitig zu sowieso geh da sind jetzt
hier nicht schneller
guck mal mein schatz endlich sind wir
urlaub ja sagt hierzu bin ich hier und
der strand wäre auch viel schöner wenn
der sand feiner wer allerdings warum ist
der sonnenuntergang nicht so schön da
ist der konsequenz also die nicht nur
gegen andere über meckern sondern auch
für sich selber weg
woher kommt das alles kommt sicher aus
dieser direktheit auch raus glaube ich
also aber keine ahnung was denkt ihr
[Applaus]
unser zweites thema jetzt ist die
deutschen die sprechen überall wo sie
hinkommen deutsch gott ja das stimmt
der ist auch schon aufgefallen überall
selbst die speisekarte hier ist deutsch
also dass dieses ressort ist noch
ausgelegt auf deutsche touristen
offensichtlich aber trotzdem das ist mir
auch schon woanders aufgefallen nicht
nur hier in ägypten deutsche gehen immer
davon aus dass andere leute auf der welt
deutschen ja das stimmt aber das wird
ihnen auch angeboten von total
überrascht gestern bereich zum beispiel
im kleinen supermarkt ihren dann kommt
eine frau rein und ohne hallo zu sagen
oder sich zum grüßen oder irgendwelche
anderen möglichen höflichkeitsfloskeln
zu benutzen
geht sie einfach direkt wo ist denn hier
die zahnpasta ich habe mich so geschämt
warum warum ist denn die deutschen sich
warum sagt man nicht mehr her salam
aleikum oder hello i
kennst du ja ist euch das auch schon mal
passiert
[Musik]
unser nächstes thema wie passend
liegestühle reservieren die deutschen
also ich hab das schon so oft gehört in
meinem leben und ich habe es noch nie
gesehen ist ein großer stereotyp und
jetzt hab ich gemerkt das stimmt morgen
stehen die deutschen auf und bevor sie
überhaupt frühstücken hinlegen sie haben
sich auf ihre liegestühle um sie für den
ganzen tag zu reservieren matthias ja
selbst wir haben es nicht geschafft
irgendwie stelle zu bekommen weil schon
alles reserviert war wie wir noch
früchte kommen sonst wir können immer
erst mittags im pool gehen wenn die
ersten schon wieder schlafen kalt die
europäer sind ja auch nichts gewöhnt und
vor allen dingen ist der pool beheiztem
tibetischer wir gehen immer nur in einem
beheizten pool im urlaub irgendwie
mohsen matthias unser nächstes thema auf
dieser wunderschönen in den inseln ist
deutsche fühlen sich super schnell
beleidigt oder sogar angegriffen weil
sie im smalltalk deutschen können die
sind super schlechteren und kennen das
nicht dass jemand deutsche sind ja immer
effizient und wir kennen das nicht dass
jemand ohne absicht ihn redet also
einfach fragen wie es gilt und deutsche
verbunden hinter jedem kleinen gespräch
immer direkt seine absicht wir wieder
hin das verkaufen oder für wasser kaufen
[Musik]
deutschland muss aber deswegen verhalten
die sich mancher komischen tier ist das
ganz typisch so die ägypter sind immer
super nett und sie sagen den
ganzheitlich scherz oder sprüche die
kräftig zu und sagen hey wie gehts dir
oder das fragte was kostet das in diesen
fünf millionen dollar und die deutschen
lachen ist euch das schon mal
aufgefallen die wir zuschauer schreibt
es uns in die kommentare
[Musik]
wieso das heißt wie lange schon wieder
nicht wir sind jetzt hier gerade in die
präsidentensuite eingebrochen
ich glaube wir dürfen hier gar nicht
rein
punkt 5 auf unserer liste der typisch
deutschen angewohnheiten im ausland ist
ungeduldig sein
bist du ungewöhnlich matthias ich bin
wahnsinnig ungeduldig ja aber ich lasse
das nicht so aufscheinen weil wir sind
jetzt sehr höflich der österreicher was
machst du denn dann wenn irgendwie
jemand sagt ich hol dich um 8 uhr ab
oder ist erzählen noch nicht da rufst du
dann nicht an und sagt hallo bleibt
student schreibt ganz eine freundliche
messe zu sagen hallo ich steht da und da
bist du bald da fragezeichen drei
smileys deutsche sind wahnsinnig
ungewöhnlich und weil unsere art es ja
ist sehr direkt zu sein
beschweren wir uns dann auch direkt also
das heißt das muss dann auch raus
irgendwie der frust typische typisches
beispiel
und das was mich aber ärgert ist dass
die deutschen nicht mal locker lassen
kann
wir können nicht einfach sagen wir sagen
hey wir sind im urlaub ist egal ob jetzt
um 9 oder um 10 uhr irgendwo hinfahren
und es wird eh schon passen
typisches beispiel wir sind in in einem
afrikanischen land und uns wird gesagt
haben abzug kommt der bus der wohl durch
ab um 10 uhr ist er wusste noch nicht da
wir sitzen in der prallen sonne alle
deutschen sind haben sich schon
wahnsinnig aufgeregt und da kommt der
bus um 11 dann steigen wir alle ein
was steht da wo es noch eine stunde und
ja man kann dann natürlich lachen das
wären etwa oder sich einfach gut fühlen
oder was anderes machen sich unterhalten
aber der deutsche der villa effizienz
der will losfahren man darf den humor
einfach nicht verlieren aber wenn man da
keinen hart kann man auch gern keinen
verlieren
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
matthias unter letzter und sechster
punkte hessen gastfreundschaft
die deutschen haben es ja nicht so mit
der gastfreundschaft und ich glaube
meine österreich ist es ein bisschen
ähnlich stimmt hast ja ist ganz ähnlich
also wie merke dass immer erst im
ausland wenn das wir so rüberkommen wie
rüberkommen
das heißt denn ausland wie ist man da zu
dir also ich hab selten so krasse gras
vor rechenschafts gesehen wie in ägypten
aber generell ist gastfreundschaft ein
riesiges hohes gut für ganz viele
kulturen
das merkt man immer wieder nur nicht bei
uns richtig
also wir würden schon mal leute zum
essen einladen und freundlich sein aber
das was man hier anstellt und
gastfreundschaft zu zelebrieren ist echt
schon ein anderes level als zum ersten
mal nach ägypten gekommen wenn er weiß
in kairo unterwegs so meine freunde
haben sich darum gestritten wer uns um
drei uhr nachts vom flughafen abholt bei
uns in deutschland hätten wir nicht
einen finger gerührt schon gar nicht
hätten wir uns darum gestritten
und ich habe auch angeboten wir kommen
wir im taxi fahren und es war ihnen
richtig immens wichtig dass sie uns
persönlich abholen und es ging dann eine
woche so wir zusammen sind rausgegangen
zum essen wir haben nie was bezahlt die
leute haben es ständig eingeladen und es
war es richtig unangenehm nach einer
zeit freundlichen unangenehm weil wir
das meistens jahre zurückgeben
also es ist das wäre etwas anders wenn
es dann irgendwie weg gibt es die server
ist das schlimmste als deutscher bekomme
ich geschenke als gast und als gastgeber
das heißt wenn mich die leute in
deutschland besuchen
letztens war sogar eine frau die hat bei
uns bei erwin wie gewohnt die hat sogar
bezahlt die kameras israel hat bezahlt
dafür dass über uns übernachtet und hat
uns geschenke da gelassen und als ich
zum beispiel ich war mal eine woche im
oman
da musste ich den ganzen koffer kaufen
für meine geschenke suchen dich wieder
nach hause zurück und peinlich die
deutschen haben nie westerwelle
ja das kenne ich sie nehmen weil man
reisen immer kleine sachen wie die
mozartkugeln oder so aber wenn du nach
brasilien vortrag immer also massenweise
geschenk geben was man immer platz frei
machen wirklich großartig eigentlich
stellst du dich manchmal dass wir das
nicht machen ein bisschen was heißt das
schon aufgefallen die deutschen geben
euch nichts und er gibt ihnen alles
schreibt uns bitte einen kommentar und
es tut uns leid des tun deswegen ist es
einfach unsere kultur
[Musik]
ja liebe zuschauer das war unsere
episode aus ägypten mit den sechs
typischen dingen die deutsche im urlaub
machen
danke dass ihr zu gesehen habt jetzt
möchten natürlich von euch wissen fandet
ihr die sachen gut timo hatte erzählt
haben ist euch das auch schon mal
aufgefallen oder stimmen diese dinge
überhaupt nicht was ist eure erfahrungen
schreibt uns unten rein und wenn ihr
lust habt übungen zu machen das
vokabular aus dieser episode noch mal zu
vertiefen dann wäre bei uns einen patch
1 matthias auch schon klatschen also
nicht nur der größte fans sondern
natürlich auch bertram mit patch 1 könnt
ihr unser projekt unterstützen und wir
finanzieren unser projekt darüber
deswegen freuen uns sehr wenn ihr
mitmacht danke fürs zuschauen und bis
bald